hi Michael here from the climate YouTube
channel distilled I'm taking over for
Simon while he's on paternity leave I'm
also here to tell you about what I think
might just be the most Overlook climate
solution in the world now when we
typically think of climate Solutions I
think most of us think of one of two
categories first we obviously think of
the popular stuff like solar panels and
wind turbines and electric vehicles and
this makes sense given the amount of
news coverage these Solutions receive
and the large role they'll play in
decarbonization and then people also
think of the futuristic cool stuff you
might think of room temperature
superconductor that could pave the way
for efficient High-Speed Rail networks
all around the world or maybe you think
of fusion power plants that could
provide cheap abundant clean energy for
all or maybe you think of direct air
capture plants that could suck gigatons
of carbon out of the sky come to think
of it I guess all the futuristic stuff
is also the most controversial anyway
what we generally don't think of are the
boring but incredibly important
solutions that we need to decarbonize
our society in some cases these
Solutions are already all around us
think LED light bulbs which are
dramatically more efficient than
incandescent bulbs or in other cases
they're nent like zero emissions
Concrete in this video I want to
convince you that one of these boring
climate Solutions is actually really
cool and Incredibly exciting I want to
make the case that if we want to avoid a
climate catastrophe we should all pay a
little bit more attention to the humble
heat pump at an individual level a heat
pump powered by renewable electricity
can cut a person's carbon footprint by
more than 50% globally this technology
can reduce billions of tons of emissions
each year all while saving people money
on their utility bill and they can do
all of this while providing air
conditioning in a rapidly warming World
literally saving lives but before
looking at all these benefits in more
detail and how these things work we have
to look at how our current way of
heating and cooling buildings got us
into such a mess in the first place for
the vast majority of history people were
either too hot or too cold most of the
time but humans are a clever Bunch so we
eventually figured out how to solve this
problem we invented fireplaces furnaces
and eventually air conditioning now this
was great for living standards you're
probably sitting in an air conditioned
or heated room right now as a result of
these inventions but the problem is that
space Heating and Cooling takes a
massive amount of energy and today most
of that energy is powered by fossil
fuels according to the International
Energy agency buildings are responsible
for 30% of all energy use globally the
energy used in buildings is responsible
for 26% of energy related emissions and
heating and cooling alone are
responsible for 40% of those emissions
that means that heating and cooling
buildings is responsible for 10% of all
emissions globally that's as much
pollution as all passenger vehicles in
the world in order to reduce these
emissions we need to do two things first
we need to make all buildings way more
efficient the reality is that today most
buildings just waste a ton of energy we
can improve efficiency by adding
insulation upgrading windows and
installing smart thermostats to name
just a few opportunities but even if we
dramatically improved Energy Efficiency
in buildings that wouldn't be enough
we'd still be burning huge amounts of
fossil fuels each year resulting in far
too much carbon pollution so we also
need to swap out all fossil fuel
appliances with electric alternative Now
by this point I'm sure that somebody's
already paused the video to write me a
comment and let me know that electricity
is produced using fossil fuels and
generally speaking that's true today but
it doesn't have to be as you can see in
this graphic there's a huge variance in
the emissions intensity of electric
grids around the world some countries
like Norway and France run on much
cleaner fuels than others these
countries show that it's possible to
build clean and reliable electric grids
if we can Electrify everything and then
build clean grids all around the world
we can cut most building emissions and
this is where heat pumps come in at the
simplest level a heat pump is an
appliance that can both heat and cool a
building it's like an air conditioner
that you can flip into reverse if you
want to heat your room but unlike a
fossil fuel furnace or boiler heat pumps
run on electricity this means that they
can eventually be powered by renewable
energy the fact that heat pumps can also
provide air conditioning is a huge
benefit today billions of people living
in warm climates don't have access to
air conditioning the third major benefit
of this technology is efficiency fossil
fuel furnaces and boilers typically run
90 to 95% of efficiency which might
sound pretty good that means that they
waste just 5 to 10% of their energy but
heat pumps are 300 to 400% efficient
which means that when you put one unit
of energy in you get more than one unit
of energy out to understand how heat
pumps achieve this efficiency let's take
a look at how these things work one of
the key things to understand about heat
pumps is that they move heat rather than
generate it in cooling mode a heat pump
moves heat from inside your home to the
outside air leaving it cooler
refrigerators and air conditioners do
the same thing that's why if you put
your hand behind in a refrigerator or
next to the outside unit of an air
conditioner you'll feel hot air this is
heat that's been moved from one place to
another but what makes a heat pump
different than a traditional air
conditioner is that this process can be
reversed on a cold day a heat pump can
move heat from the outside air into your
home and that's kind of crazy because
modern heat pumps work down to -20° F or
-30 C so how is this possible the second
law of Thermodynamics tells us that hot
always wants to move to cold it also
tells us that the ultimate fate of the
universe is heat death but that's beside
the point heat pumps take advantage of
this law to simplify things a bit heat
pumps have both an inside and outside
unit connected by tubes with a
refrigerant inside in cooling mode a
heat pump uses the refrigeration cycle
to get a refrigerant really cold and
pass it through coils in the inside unit
then a fan blows the warm air in your
room over those cold coils because the
inside air is warmer than the coils some
of the heat moves to the coils and the
refrigerant in this way heat is pumped
out of the building leaving the inside
air cooler in the winter this whole
process is reversed and heat is pumped
from the outside air into your home at
first this is a little hard to wrap your
head around if it's 10° outside how is
there any heat to pump into the building
but here's the thing even on a cold day
there's energy in the air at a
microscopic level heat is basically just
molecules bouncing around and while they
might be bouncing around slower on a
cold day they're still moving about in
fact there would be energy in the air
all the way down to - 459 Fen or -273 CS
the temperature known as absolute zero
heat pumps take advantage of this too on
a cold day the refrigerant is cooled to
a temperature even colder than the
surrounding air enabling it to absorb
heat as it passes through the outside
unit when it passes through the inside
unit the heat is released since the
refrigerant is warmer than the inside
air and it turns out this is an
incredibly efficient way to move heat
from one place to another by using just
a small amount of electricity heat pumps
can use just one unit of energy to move
three or four units of energy and this
is what makes them so efficient so why
aren't we using these things to heat and
cool our buildings ultimately it comes
down to cost but not necessarily in ways
you might expect in 1938 on the eve of
World War II Swiss Engineers installed
Europe's first heat pump in Zurich City
Hall the next year as the War Began
Germany cut off coal exports to
Switzerland driving heat pump adoption a
decade later coal shortages led the UK
to explore heat pumps for the first time
too in the 1950s Parliament discussed
heat pumps as a potential solution to
the country's falling coal stocks but
the heat pump Market didn't truly take
off until the oil crisis of the 1970s as
OPEC cut off oil exports to America and
European countries policy makers looked
for ways to save energy and they found a
great solution in heat pumps during the
crisis governments around the world
passed policies pushing heat pump
adoption in the US heat pump sales grew
by 500% in the 1970s from 100,000 units
sold per year to 500,000 but by the
1980s Energy prices all around the world
had fallen and as a result gas furnaces
and boilers have been the cheapest
Heating option for the last few decades
however some countries continued to
invest in Energy Efficiency even as
Energy prices fell in Japan a country
with almost no fossil fuel reserves the
government continued to invest in heat
pumps today 90% of homes in the country
have a heat pump recently Europe entered
a new era of energy scarcity as Russia
invaded Ukraine as Energy prices
skyrocketed so did heat pump sales in
some countries like Poland and Belgium
heat pump sales doubled in a single year
in other countries like the UK France
and Germany sales grew by 40 to 60% and
so the first reason why we don't use
heat pumps more is because generally
speaking fossil fuels are cheap and
abundant but when we look at the cost of
anything we can't just look at the
monetary price one reason that fossil
fuels and the appliances that run on
them are so cheap is because we Overlook
the true cost they impose on society and
this is the second reason why heat pumps
aren't more popular fossil fuel heating
systems create a lot of pollution and
this pollution creates an enormous cost
on society poor air quality results in
worse productivity hospitalization and
millions of deaths each year and that's
just the short-term impact over the
longer term this pollution results in
climate damage that's measured in
billions and trillions of dollars some
countries recognize this sooner than
others in the 1990s Sweden passed a
carbon tax to put a price on pollution
this tax has been one of the major
drivers of heat pump adoption in the
country today 40% of homes in Sweden
have a heat pump the third largest share
in Europe so why don't more countries
have carbon taxes like Sweden after all
if they did we'd have more heat pumps
and less pollution this brings me to the
third reason why heat pumps aren't more
popular the global fossil fuel Lobby in
2022 fossil fuel companies received a
staggering 1 trillion dollars in
subsidies from governments around the
world in many countries like mine these
companies have effectively bought the
government this makes their product
artificially cheap but it also enables
them to fend off competitors like heat
pumps a few years ago cities in the US
like Berkeley California passed laws
Banning fossil fuel heating systems
citing their carbon pollution and damage
the city wanted homeowners to install
heat pumps instead fearing a broader
Trend fossil fuel companies convince
lawmakers in 23 out of 50 states to ban
these bans a political tactic known as
preemption this is one of the most
direct attempts by the industry to slow
heat pump adoption but it's not the
first for decades gas companies have
been spreading misinformation about heat
pumps if you've ever heard that heat
pumps don't work in cold climates you
can probably thank your local gas
company these companies have even paid
Tik Tok influencers to spread this myth
but make no mistake today's heat pumps
work down to -20° F or or -30° C just
ask Scandinavians in Norway Finland and
Sweden the three countries in Europe
with the most heat pumps per capita
another myth the fossil fuel Lobby is
spread is that the electric grid can't
handle heat pumps there are plenty of
countries with both High penetration of
heat pumps and renewable energy Norway
the country with the most heat pumps per
capita in Europe also has the cleanest
grid I'll link to a great mythbuster by
rewiring America with more on this topic
below today just 10% of global space
heating needs are met by heat pumps in
order to avoid a climate disaster we
need to bring this number closer to 100%
over the next few decades it's a
daunting task but with action from
people like me and you it's absolutely
possible the easiest thing that we can
all do is talk about heat pumps with our
friends and family today most people
simply don't know that this technology
exists we need to change that the second
thing we can all do is get politically
active the only way we'll get our
governments to take on the fossil fuel
Lobby is by electing climate leaders and
then holding them accountable finally
the next time your furnace or air
conditioner goes out consider installing
a heat pump in many places your local
government will give you thousands of
dollars in rebates to do so unlike many
climate Solutions the technology for
heat pumps has been developed and tested
for decades now it's up to all of us to
get this technology out in the world if
you enjoyed this video and want to learn
more about other climate Solutions
please consider subscribing to my
YouTube channel distilled every couple
weeks I publish a video exploring how we
can build a more sustainable world I've
covered everything from solar water
heaters to bike Lanes to geothermal if
you head over there be sure to say hello
in the comments I'd love to welcome you
to the community